welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul
aka the guy who's going to take you
through the alpha and amiga of star wars
the bad batch episode 2.
throughout this video we'll be recapping
the plot pointing out the easter eggs
and things you missed
as well as giving our theories on where
the show might be going in the future
full spoilers ahead so if you haven't
had a chance to check it out yet then i
highly recommend that you check out now
as always if you like the video you will
click the thumbs up button
and subscribe for breakdowns like this
each and every day
you couldn't see there but i was
actually jedi mind tricking you to do
that
so thanks for the thumbs up now let's
get into the bad batch episode 2.
so in this episode a miracle happened
i actually got a fan theory right
[Music]
so that cancels out all the 700 we got
wrong and we're now officially the most
reliable source of star wars nonsense
this side of mos eisley episode 1 ended
with the group flying off to meet an old
ally
and it turns out it's cut laquan a clone
trooper who deserted his post in order
to carve out a life for himself
the episode itself is called cut and run
which is not only a nod to laquan's
first name
but also towards him deserting the army
and his home
what's cut's favorite meal dessert thank
you i'm here all week now he very much
reflects the bad batch
and offers a glimmer of hope that it is
possible to have a life outside of what
they were born in breadfall
now in case you don't know the history
mcqueen was a clone trooper whose
transport was attacked after the first
battle of geonosis
droids swarmed the area and started to
exterminate all those that survived
and the queen ended up fleeing in order
to live he deserted his post
and instead carved out a life for
himself with a twilight called sue
and her children rex and le quaine
crossed paths
and the former agreed not to report him
and the character has lived a very
peaceful life on the form
since then the rex does get name dropped
at one point in the episode
and after the ending of the clone wars
there was still a lot of questions up in
the air
over exactly what it was that was
happening with him it looks like he's
still keeping in touch with his old pals
i think we will likely run into him very
shortly on the show
at one point they discussed the
inhibitor chip implant which was a big
plot point for the character
in the final four episodes of the clone
wars also quick correction for episode 1
last video i said they were from batch
99 but actually named after the
defective clone from batch 99
who died during the invasion of kamino
shout outs to everyone who pointed that
out in the last video now we begin with
the group in space
and echo makes it very clear that he
doesn't think they should have a child
with them
this is something hunter very much
wrestles with throughout the episode
and he goes back and forth over what
life's best for her
they arrive at salukimai and see aneksu
which
you might recognize from the attack of
the clones these cat-like creatures
possess
four eyes two of which give them
incredible sight
and the other two allow them to see an
infrared they run the area but are kept
out of the queen's home
by his extremely thin wire fence and
booby traps
now i love amiga in this episode and i
know there's people saying that
she's just this show's grogu but i think
she works really well with the rest of
the cast
because she's never left kamino seeing
her grab the dirt as she lands is a
great thing to witness
and i believe she's very much gonna grow
into a strong warrior throughout the
season
the clone wars rebels and star wars in
general
is full of kids who turn into jedis or
sharpshooters
and i can very much see this being the
case with her they make the trek to the
farm
and after wreckers brings a battle droid
booby trap suing could come into play
sue is brandishing a cyclo rifle and
they take them to their house to explain
the situation
now what i love about this series is
that it's showcasing the transition
between the clone wars and the original
trilogy
there was a big grey area in star wars
law in which
we know that the clones were replaced
but didn't quite see the transition
i think we are seeing very much the
mentality of adapt or die
and last episode we witnessed as clones
were even turning on other clones
believing themselves to be superior
however they really aren't and whilst
this conversation was going on
the empire was talking about
discontinuing them it's very political
and laced with the idea that governments
will say that they're there for the
people
but in reality they're happy to cast
them aside once they achieve their goals
the troopers probably would have been
better off under the jedi but they're
led to believe that the change they're
now a part of is better
even though we know it leaves them
extinct now it's at this point they
bring rex up
and the inhibitor chip hunter is shocked
to learn that the free will of the
clones can be controlled through this
and i think it's setting the groundwork
for the rescue of crosshair in which
they will remove it from his head
the kids come in and amiga starts a
friendship with them
even though they're calling her omega
and i tell you what right
i got into a massive argument once with
someone in the comments
because i pronounced it boba fett they
were adamant that you could only ever
pronounce it boba fett
and i said look yeah a lot of star wars
names are said differently in
in the same movie sometimes they
disagreed and i hope this guy's watching
how they pronounce amiga different ways
crying because i haven't forgotten yet
i'll never forget
anyway amiga actually has some fun for
once and we learned last week that she
was pretty much
created to be a medical assistant we're
told that she's a defective clone
but as cute says this means that she
still has a purpose
now the bad match themselves were bred
to see if there could be different
traits within fett's dna
that could be amplified or changed to
make a more adept soldier
it sort of hints towards a theory going
around at the moment that amiga is
actually the first attempt at creating a
force-sensitive clone
in the mandalorian we of course learned
that the empire were very close to
creating one
and though they didn't use the kaminoans
for this it is possible that they
themselves tried to duplicate someone
who could use the force
now shout out to ryan arya at
screencrush for pointing out that the
word omega itself
means the end perhaps hinting to her
being the final thing that the kaminoans
were aiming towards
last episode they hinted out waiting
until the empire had revealed their
plans before showing their hand
and this it's clear that she's very
different to the typical grunt
at this point the big twist in star wars
is that everyone's a clone of palpatine
and i know a lot of you out there think
that amiga is too
i'm still kind of getting hung up on the
accent a bit and with her sounding
similar to the clones
i do think that she's more in line with
them she does have that palpatine
haircut though however
i think that she will simply be force
sensitive but not related to anyone we
know so far
anyway it's at this point that cut says
he's leaving the planet and that rex
brought with him a warning
the empire is slowly taking over and he
has to do what's best for his family and
get out of dodge
whilst he still can this makes hunter
wonder about what's best for amiga
and we cut to the town center here we
get a brief look at a landspeeder
which bears similar colours to luke's
and hunter looks
even more like rambo than ever before i
love as the shadow of an imperial ship
flies overhead
and this metaphorically shows the
darkness that is starting to seep into
the city
we learn that they have been seizing
ships and the imperial's mode of
operation as a whole
tends to be to take what they want and
destroy all those who resist
cup plans to find a remote piece of land
on a distant planet
and he inquires with an alien called
aniline who you might recognize as being
from the same species as the podracer
rats
she tells them there's a newly
implemented galactic policy
that means you must have a chain code in
order to leave the planet
they are also registering people
something that was forced on the jewish
population in poland
during the second world war this means
that their inability to leave
is limited and that the population can
be controlled by the empire
should they wish to amiga goes beyond
the perimeter
and the nexus slowly creeps in to kill
her she saved by sue and hunter
which makes the latter brighter like a
soldier
cut actually treats her like a child and
hunter further gets it in his mind that
she will be safer with him
also i love how raka wears a grey poncho
with burgundy coloring on it
which is of course not only a style of
the rebels but also the title screen of
the show
now on the ship amiga removes the
jewelry from her head
this is something that the cloners wear
showing that she is slowly starting to
step away from her past
it's also at this point her hair changes
cementing that
she is actually a clone of luke
skywalker
now tech and echo get this [ __ ] i mean
i'm being sarcastic
by the way now tech and echo get the
ship impounded with them on board
and this takes them to the insides of
the spaceport detention center
unfortunately amiga is on the ship at
this point and thus hunter and co
launch a rescue mission now we also
overhear the troopers saying that the
ship is a modified omicron attack
shuttle
omicron is actually a letter from the
taiwanese alphabet
which was used against the imperial
fleet showcasing how a lot of the clone
trooper designations were brought over
to be used by the imperials
they sneak to a security booth which you
might notice is similar to the one used
in solo a star wars story
this is the place where the infamous
line han
han solo that is your new name mate so
you're calling yourself that from now on
was uttered by
a god the whole chain code thing in
general does feel like it lines up
massively with that film
and how hand promised daenerys that they
would run away together before jon snow
could kill her
something like that i don't know i spent
most of the air drunk anyway echo hacks
the door using a key rod
that is very similar to the one that
r2d2 has
this unlocks the safe with the chain
codes inside and the family travel to
the barrier in order to get off world
amiga gets caught and wrecker saves her
but the shooting starts
and thus the group have to act fast
during these scenes you get a brief
glimpse of a similar droid to 88
who you may recognize from jabba's
palace we learn that they got an
extra chain card for amiga to have the
life she deserves
but as we've seen the clones share a
certain brotherhood
or rather sisterhood and she decides to
go with them
hunt helps to save his bros as they try
and turn off the magnets clamping their
ship in place
and wrecker shows why he's the strongest
avenger once more
by pulling it apart with his bare hands
cut is almost cut by a clone
but because of the chaos caused by the
bad batch the troopers are summoned away
now you can also see them using blue
lasers in this battle which are
typically associated with stun
showing that they still have a
brotherhood with the clones and don't
want to hurt them
they managed to make it off world and we
cut to rekka using a gunk droid as a
barbell and amiga says that the group
are who she wants to be with and she's
obviously gonna have to level up
slightly in order to keep up with their
crazy shenanigans
and in the trailers there is a shot in
which we can see her sporting a bow and
arrow
they're gonna katniss her she's she's
gonna be the new katniss you just watch
now i really hope we start seeing some
of her training soon
and i think she's gonna be a really good
character now again this was a great
episode
and i've loved the first two i feel like
it's gonna get better and better
and excuse me for sounding like a noob
but at the moment it seems like more
adult animation is starting to get
accepted into the mainstream
i know this isn't fully adult animation
and it's not as gory or as bloody as
invincible
but it's nice that stories which don't
pander to kids
are starting to get watched more and
more by general audiences
the show deserves it and hopefully it's
going to be something that improves
every single week
until we get to the plot reveal that it
was palpatine
all along now obviously i'd love to hear
your thoughts on the show
so make sure you comment below and let
me know as a thank you for interacting
with the video you'll be entered into a
prize store on the 30th of may
in which we're giving away three copies
of the godzilla versus kong collection
all you have to do to begin with the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the episode the winners of
last month's competition are on screen
right now
so if that's you then message me on
twitter heavyspoilers if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our breakdown of the first
episode which will be linked on screen
right now
going over the entire thing just like
this one pointing out some of the easter
eggs
made some mistakes about it being batch
99 and just generally had a bit of a
laugh
but out of the way thank you for sending
me through the video i've been poor i'll
see you next time
take care peace